Speaker 1: So yesterday we talked about Dr.
Anthony Fauci, his recent statement that again,
we always want to be clear not to overplay
our hand.
Dr. Fauci
Speaker 2: on Monday said, which I told you
Speaker 1: about yesterday.
Anecdotal early data points in a general way
towards Omicron, the new COVID variant probably
causing on average less severe disease.
That's like a lot of hedging and caveats,
but that's sort of where our knowledge is
at this point in time.
We have another slightly stronger statement
from Dr. Fauci, which I'm going to get to
in a moment.
But first, I want to address something.
Many of you have been emailing me about
Speaker 2: saying, David, sir, why
Speaker 1: is it if all Macron is less severe,
that cases are spiking now?
Cases and severity are two different things,
Speaker 2: but the first question we have
to
Speaker 1: answer to even do this is answer
the question.
Our case is
Speaker 2: spiking and if so,
Speaker 1: are they Omicron spikes or not?
Let's start with the numbers.
Are cases spiking?
Yes, very, very much so.
Insane numbers in the United States, cases
are now up to about one hundred and seventeen
thousand per day.
They were down to seventy two thousand per
day in their recent bottom.
Now up to one hundred and seventeen thousand
per day, that's a huge increase, nearly a
two thirds increase, 63 percent higher cases
per day in the U.S.
The same thing is happening globally, where
cases spiked from a low of about 400000 a
day, still a crazy number up to 600 and 11000
cases per day.
That's an increase of 5.2 percent globally.
Speaker 2: So are cases spiking without a
doubt?
Speaker 1: Way, way, way up.
It's not only cases that are spiking.
Hospitalizations are also way up in the United
States.
We now are about 6000 new hospitalizations
for COVID per day.
We had been down to about 2500 at one point
over the summer.
But the key question is, is this a sign of
Omicron spreading wildly and putting people
in the hospital?
And so far the answer is no.
It appears that while a higher percentage
Speaker 2: of new cases are Omicron
Speaker 1: higher and higher over time, the
current spike in cases is being driven by
the Delta variant and the rise in hospitalizations
definitely being driven by the Delta variant,
Speaker 2: per some
Speaker 1: analyzes
Speaker 2: now on Omicron.
Speaker 1: We also heard from Dr. Fauci again,
and Dr. Fauci is now speaking with slightly
more certainty, slightly more definitive ness,
who says that it's going to take weeks to
know for sure.
But early indications suggest that the severity
Speaker 2: of
Speaker 1: Omicron cases is no worse than
previous strains and possibly milder,
Speaker 2: which would be very welcome.
Speaker 1: The not so good it spreads like
Speaker 2: wildfire reinfections appear to
be
Speaker 1: higher,
Speaker 2: but on severity.
Dr. Fauci saying it almost
Speaker 1: certainly is not more severe than
Delta now.
Still, if it's as severe and more contagious,
it's not a big victory, and it's going to
take more time to determine the specifics.
We're also getting more and more anecdotes
about just how easily Omicron spreads.
Speaker 2: Last week, I
Speaker 1: spoke with Nicholas Kristof.
Speaker 2: And he talked about this anecdote,
Speaker 1: which he said is it's an important
anecdote
Speaker 2: about two
Speaker 1: travelers quarantining in Hong
Kong.
One who opened the door for room service and
then another across the hall, who later opened
the
Speaker 2: door, caught the virus.
Speaker 1: Now, as Nicholas Kristof has said,
could have.
That might not have
Speaker 2: been how we caught it.
Speaker 1: There could be more to that, but
as an anecdote,
Speaker 2: pretty, pretty horrifying stuff.
Speaker 1: Other anecdotes 69 of 150 participants
at a Danish Christmas party have now tested
positive.
For Omicron, it's about half about half of
the attendees.
Nearly 70 intensive care medics at a Spanish
hospital now have COVID after a Christmas
party.
Not yet totally clear if that's Omicron.
So we want Omicron to be milder.
It's clearly very contagious, and we're going
to have to keep waiting to get definitive
information.
But the hope would be.
Equally or slightly more
Speaker 2: contagious, but dramatically
Speaker 1: less severe, particularly if there's
going to be immune evasion.
Speaker 2: That would be sort of
Speaker 1: the ideal
Speaker 2: outcome.
And remember,
Speaker 1: over time, evolutionary pressure
for these
Speaker 2: viruses is more
Speaker 1: transmissible, less severe to the
point where is could it be in a year?
Could it be two years?
Could it be five years?
I don't know.
Five years is more depressing,
Speaker 2: but it could be
Speaker 1: a very contagious cold indistinguishable
Speaker 2: from the
Speaker 1: average head cold in terms of severity.
That is the trajectory to sort of hope for
at this point in time.
And how long it'll take to become a reality
is a question that we don't yet have an answer
to.
Speaker 2: Let me know your
Speaker 1: thoughts and maybe, maybe just
as importantly, find me on Twitter at David
Pakman and let me know, are you now doing
something differently based on Omicron based
on Omicron relative to what you were doing
before?
Are you doing anything differently now?
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Let me know and remember that next Tuesday,
this coming Tuesday, December
Speaker 2: 14th, we'll be doing our
Speaker 1: next David Pakman Show Viewer Town
Hall.
We will be streaming it live on the Pacman
Live YouTube channel, and you will be able
to participate via The David Pakman Show Discord.
Remember that members
Speaker 2: will get
Speaker 1: priority access during the town
hall.
Sign up at Join Pacman dot com.
Welcome back to the show, everybody.
We are we're continuing to try to close
Speaker 2: out 2021 as strongly
Speaker 1: as possible.
I mentioned earlier this
Speaker 2: week, the last
Speaker 1: six months have been a little tougher
for the show, quite frankly.
And although the audience has kept
Speaker 2: growing, the
Speaker 1: economic situation has led to a
lot of people canceling memberships and things
are looking a little bit less good.
So I want to re
Speaker 2: invite you to sign up at
Speaker 1: join Packman dot com.
We've made an offer which several dozen folks
have availed themselves of,
Speaker 2: which is if
Speaker 1: you get a membership for the year
at full price on our website, I'll send you
a free T-shirt your of your choice you can
choose.
I mean, listen, of course you can pick the
size.
It would be crazy if I said, you have got
to have it to excel.
That would be nuts.
What kind of a host would I be?
You can pick the design.
You can pick the color.
So free T-shirt sent to you anywhere in the
world with a full price yearly membership
at Join Pacman dot com to sign up and email
info at David Pakman dot com and we'll get
that out to you ASAP.
And you can also get memberships for just
a couple of bucks a month a month.
If you use the code
Speaker 2: better 21,
Speaker 1: the Code Better 21 will give you
a big discount offer.
The membership of your choice would love for
you to sign up.